[Applause]
welcome to swipe here's what we've got
for you on this week's show Angela's in
Dublin finding out how tech startups are
faring side-by-side with the tech
giant's pedal power I test out a new
system designed to turn any bicycle into
an electric one and Lucy looks at the
latest video games and offers us the
return of a cult classic that's all
coming up for you in the next 10 minutes
or so after a quick look at some of the
tech news headlines that got us talking
this week more than a million people
have signed an online petition calling
on snapchat to undo its latest redesign
to the app the update separates
interactions with friends from public
and branded content but users say it's
annoying and has made many features more
difficult Amazon has been cleared after
one of its TV adverts triggered it's
voice-activated alexa service to order
cat food in a viewers home an echo das
owner who was able to cancel the order
had complained to the Advertising
Standards Authority saying the ad was
socially irresponsible a train station
in China that's over a hundred years old
has been given a tech upgrade to handle
the Chinese New Year Rush little un is
on hand at iun station to help
passengers there are mobile phone
charging points and face scanning
technology for checking in also in China
this week
formula e driver ho pintung drove up one
of the country's best-known landmarks
here is priming 999 steps leading to
Heaven's Gate attainment Mountain
see he was successful and not far from
Winter Olympics action this week a group
of robots took part in their own
sporting event teams put forward their
box in what organizers called the first
ever robot skiing competition we'll be
talking
pedal power in a couple of minutes first
though Islands low corporate tax rate
has long made it an attractive location
for tech giants but Dublin's got a
buzzing startup scene too one that
Angela's been to visit to find out if
having those big tech companies in town
has been a help or a hindrance the grand
canal dock area of Dublin home to the
European headquarters of some of the
world's biggest multinational tech
companies Google Facebook and LinkedIn
are just some of the recognizable names
and their presence is transforming the
city
the Irish Venture Capital Association
forecast that tech firms raised a record
1 billion euros last year that's more
than eight hundred and seventeen million
pounds the figures indicate the startup
scene is thriving but is sharing a city
with the bigger tech companies a help or
hindrance at Google we spoke to the man
in charge of helping new companies scale
and grow on a global stage so we do a
lot of work at a community engagement
ever first off so a good example of that
will be we run a our support a first
Friday's event in Dogpatch labs which is
a co-working space at the centre of the
community here in the Docklands so we
send mentors down there any startup can
apply across the country they have
people dropping in so we do a lot of
that kind of stuff and we run events
here then on a monthly basis girl crew a
social network app for women is one of
the startup success stories raising over
650,000 pounds since launching in June
this year we've been part of Google's
adopt a startup program and had members
of teams there helped us I really
directly give us advice share their
experiences with us health tech business
web doctor I II is another success story
they've raised just under 2 million
pounds but have experienced the
challenges posed by having the bigger
firms in the city obviously having the
big
multinationals here will drive up salary
costs and demand for housing but some of
the large multinationals make a real
effort to engage with the community the
likes of Facebook and Google might be
snapping up talents and making it
difficult for new companies to compete
with the packages that they're offering
but they're also significantly boosting
networking opportunities and support for
startups which adds significantly to the
Irish ecosystem top investors in the
city say they've observed other trends
we do also see a lot of as people coming
out of these companies and these are
companies that faster this culture of of
innovation of growth of scale of
ambition and we see people coming out of
these companies then into smaller
startups and smaller Irish companies for
startups in Ireland the advice from the
top think internationally very quickly
because scaling just for the Irish
market has its challenges but as a
result it's forcing entrepreneurs to aim
for a global audience early on Angela
Barnes Sky News in Dublin back here in
the UK there's a startup keen to take
you further and faster with a portable
kit they say contain any bicycle into an
electric one the team behind switch
smash their crowdfunding target through
support from backers pledging money to
help them take their prototype to market
my name's Oliver I'm proud to be a
British engineer I studied at Oxford
University and I'm dedicated to
inventing low-carbon technologies that
are good for the planet technologies
just like the switch bike conversion kit
it's a lightweight electric motor wheel
it replaces your regular bicycle wheel
and the switch power pack which contain
for battery bike controller and display
and this is what powers your bike so
this is what every customer gets yeah
that's quite heavy it's just under three
kilograms and it's actually about 50% of
the way of the normal components that go
on an electric
the system fits on to your regular
bicycle the front wheel is replaced by
one with an inbuilt hub motor before you
add other components like pedal and
brake senses so if somebody wanted an
electric boost to their cycling would
they just buy an e bike well most B
bikes as we are discussing before like
eight or ten kilograms heavier than a
regular bike and they don't handle like
regular bicycles so someone that still
wants to have a bicycle we'd need to
have one bicycle and one e bike the
battery typically lasts for twenty-five
miles with a heavier option that takes
you further how fast can you go well for
legal reasons we have to limit it to
fifty miles an hour for our US customers
we sweep up the motor to 20 miles an
hour which is the limit there it feels
like this is taking quite a while to put
together but you've any going to do it
once right well I would say it takes
about five to ten minutes to do the
initial conversion and once you've done
that is almost instant now what better
way to see the clip on system in action
than to take every kind of bicycle
imaginable for a zip around town with
some of ollies colleagues I did say
every kind of bike the electric boost
comes in when you pedal after a
crowdfunding campaign on IndieGoGo that
saw the team achieve five hundred and
seventy six percent of their funding
goal nearly a quarter of a million
pounds they've been able to get the
first batch produced in China and the
clip-on kits are due in shops in April
however each system will set you back
just under five hundred pounds like that
but remember if you're going to add
motor power to your bike at least make
sure you know how to handle it oh I'll
just stick to the scooter for now video
games time now here's Lucy
so with the announcement that we're
getting Bayonetta three Nintendo and
Platinum Games are bringing Bayonetta 1
and 2 to the Nintendo switch which is
huge so the original Bayonetta came out
almost 10 years ago now it's something
of a cult classic featuring a female
protagonist who's strong she's sexy and
the second game came out on the Wii U
and so obviously now that we're getting
number 3 we're finally getting those
games on the Nintendo switch they
haven't really changed that much but the
one big thing they're doing is that
Bayonetta 1 & 2 will be playable in 60
frames per second which for a
hack-and-slash action game like this is
super important you want to get as much
on screen as possible to really get in
that frenetic energy if you've never
played Bayonetta before and you have a
Nintendo switch then honestly this is
the pack for you through the high minds
and the whispers of the forest Sega is
from a Swedish developer hence and
what's really interesting about this
game is who is publishing it so it's EA
who are publishing this game it is from
an indie developer faier is a gorgeous
looking game you play as a fox like
creature and you are kind of going
through this beautiful looking forest
it's very colourful and dark at the same
time and this forest is being attacked
by these strange outside forces and you
as fááá are going through this forest
and you're interacting with the
creatures the flora and the fauna that
you see in the forest but what's also
really cool about this game is it kind
of bucks the trend that we see in modern
gaming where everything is kind of
handed to you you won't ever be stuck
really in a modern game because the game
will always be telling you go this way
do this talk to this person
Fay is bucking that trend and let it's
giving you all the tools and it's
letting you go out and explore forgive
me for what I'm about to
metal gear survived is the first metal
gear game that's coming out of Konami
that won't have Hideo Kojima's input so
Hideo Kojima is kind of the division
behind the Metal Gear franchise he left
the company a couple of years ago and
this is the first game they're releasing
without him so the reaction to this game
already has been quite interesting
because some people feel like it doesn't
perfectly encapsulate you know the
political intrigue that really made the
Metal Gear series special but Metal Gear
survive on its own takes place in
between Ground zeroes and the phantom
pain you can play the game by yourself
or you can play it cooperatively with
your friends where you undertake
missions together Metal Gear survive
will be using the kind of same infamous
and incredible stealth mechanics we grew
to know and love throughout the Metal
Gear series and being able to play
online with your friends is a big draw
if you want to give the game a try there
is a free beta this weekend well that's
it for this week's show don't forget to
join us again for more swype next week
and in the meantime why not follow us on
twitter at skye and you swipe so you
seen buh-bye
[Applause]
[Music]